sherine rigolade c'est cette déclaration
du professeur raoult dans un tas
consacré qui sortira demain dans ce
livre qui s'appelle ram une folie
française ariane chemin et marie france
etchegoin ont évoqué moi je - oui je
crois ont évoqué son qi quotient
intellectuel mais voici ce qu'il dit je
vais vous raconter une chose que je n'ai
confier à personne
un jour alors que j'avais 14 ans un
pédopsychiatre a dit à mon père écoutez
votre gosse à 188 laissez le faire et
tout ira bien ouais tu dois donc ouais
on l'a laissé seul à décider à 988 alors
en france sachez qu on est autour de 98
ou voilà la moyenne elle est au tour de
sang voilà 98 toi là il aurait donc
accueilli près de deux fois supérieur à
la moyenne
alors je vous dis est ce que nous on a
calculé votre client vous a demandé
faire un pic à oui j'ai les résultats
isabelle n'a pas fait mais ces bassins
non mais c'est pas grave on s'en fout
mais a su que son jeu l'est pas mais je
ne vous arrive pas les lignes se
confondent au bout d'un moment pour moi
donc ça m'a fait chier la troisième
question là on vous à vous avez trois de
cuivre c'est le chiffre que j'ai là
alors on a ensuite en numéro 1 celle qui
a le plus gros qi de l'émission ils sont
deux égalités gilles verdez 127 et
géraldine magne et 125 grammes
en numéro 3 le plus gros qi de tp mpc
nicolas pernikoff abbas a tous un petit
test après midi oui oui c'est les vrais
chiffres qu'on y donne lui en numéro 4 6
valider mailing avant la guillaume
genton à 113 103,2 cuit les autres
commencent avec son téléphone la gare
est pas très bien non parce que
j'entends encore un téléphone sonne et
ça va jouer il va prendre dans la gueule
on fait venir chez moi c'est vrai c'est
moi alors les chéris ensuite à 102 cuit
il reste delphine et benjamins
il y aura un ou une qui a eu 50 ha merde
la moyenne vous avez dit la moyenne des
français c'est 98 98 à dire que c'est
une personne car presque la moitié de la
moitié de l'ensemble des français
tarascon a soumis à tous les chroniques
c'est le vrai test 1 c'est le jeu vous
dire
ça se joue entre delphine et benjamin
delphine ça va ça va il s'est bien passé
à fort boyard
j'ai chanté avec dave j'ai réalisé un de
mes rêves donné peut-être 1 à 10
[Applaudissements]
alors que samedi ça va très bien c'est
juste une petite question vous avez reçu
ce test par mail ceci explique peut-être
cela enfin problèmes visuels celui qui a
58 de qi c'est bah ça m'agace et bien
sûr elle trizza gens bien bas jamais
vous avez eu 58 de qi mais il ya deux
places intéressantes c'est toi vous êtes
tout en haut
cette fois tout en bas donc j'ai un peu
rire elle m'avait souvent la même place
j'ai répondu à john un peu à peu
rapidement quelqu'un qui n'est que ça
c'est un cube en de chèvre si on est
mieux que 58 c'est vraiment ces genres
une chef qui suivaient pas ajouté
mais voilà ça c'est valable pour vous
mais pas pour moi mais mais non c'est
très très bon en tout cas voilà au
réveil on a fait l'état tu as fait ton
cul ical ou pas j'ai abandonné
je vais arrêter non non vous avez bien
serait conclu et vous en aurez des
surprises
jamais une surprise mais attention ça
n'a rien à voir avec la science et la
lozère logis et voici un garçon
intelligent
ah ouais mais nice est très sexy au
modelage avec mariama vous avez souvent
vu vous avez souvent que les hommes qui
ne sont pas particulièrement avec de
très jolies femmes par exemple pas
regarder et hirson pas forcément fortune
expérience et l'intelligence peut rendre
vraiment être sympa surtout vent riches
quand même quand les mecs intelligents
et qui n'ont annoncé pas voyant ses
valeurs ses membres est chez lui dès
qu'on allait avec con comme une pendule
très riche
j'ai vu des mecs très intelligent et
vous voilà monsieur moi mon mari fait
partie des 5 % des gens une plus
intelligent dans le monde sait les tests
qui a eu tout à fait officiellement levé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si ça se voit pas toujours d'accord
gilbert del confetto géraldine c'est
important pour vous un garçon
intelligent
bah oui mais benjamin pour moi est très
intime aussi je veux dire la vérité
lithium civil
je vous jure que c'est vrai avant qu'il
passe le test j'étais persuadé que
c'était bon j'arrête parce que pour moi
c'est souvent j'ai fait 10 à glidji
répondu je préviens pas d'accord tu
pourrais dernier à et au stand blagnac
en mer et télévision spectacle show ah
ouais on est quelque chose en première
partie
[Rires]
mais en fait il ya plusieurs intelligent
st gallen milan c'est émotionnel
l'assurance sociale l'intelligence tout
ça c'était très merge ozon quest et paal
que des marques des trucs bien sortie
pour des chouettes ont démarré sur tech
la moyenne oui mais je pensais que ça
s'était bien mais en fait apparemment
c'est je suis avec des amis dans les
entrevues vous avez dit que la moyenne
se vendent en moyenne française vous
avez le bac avec ça moi c'est oui j'ai
une ancienne voilà bravo donc à vous
vous avez fait le test c'est l'essentiel
et quand on peut vous donner un petit
peu de travail l'après midi excusez moi
c'était payant c'est pareil plus
d'aboutir enfin à 92 et commun
très belle production ont dit qu'ils
aient les mêmes a écouté bravo la
production
[Applaudissements]